right now is the 30th anniversary of the
Apple Macintosh and we're very lucky
we've actually got the real thing so I'd
like to take you through some of the
features of it and make you guessed with
amazement at how much you cost how it
works and to marvel at the fact that
although it will seem very basic when I
show it to you this was absolutely
groundbreaking it's completely new
computing paradigm I've actually
upgraded this thing over the years it's
got a hard disk underneath but I won't
turn the hard disk on for the moment let
me just give you the experience of what
it was like with the original Mac which
is what this was although it has been
upgraded just switch it on and wait and
pretty soon you'll be amazed it's not
color but it has for 1984 when this came
out got the most amazing thing of a
totally bitmapped screen so it's
blinking a question mark and that is
telling you that it expects to boot by
default from a floppy disk you put in
the Mac operating system on a floppy
disk you boot it up you wait patiently
while it's got the operating system
software inside it then you forgot to
decide which particular application you
want to use so that probably involves
digging out yet more floppy disks with
Mac Wright or Microsoft Word or
something on them that is what it was
like and just to hammer home the point
here we have Adobe Acrobat version 1 so
even at this date which was in 1993 I
think when this came out this was the
way you got your distributions for a
Macintosh we're a little bit upset with
this we can load the Acrobat software
but unfortunately we don't have a key to
unlock it and make it start we're
desperately trying to get one from Adobe
because that's quite an heirloom that is
so you can imagine the pain of how to
run everything on floppy disks and the
big day came fairly soon in Mac
evolution when you could buy an optional
extra hard disk this one the road I'm
one here is 20 megabytes
let's switch it on back in the early
days of the computer science group which
was just becoming the department
computer science 1984 1985 time we did
buy the back half dozen of these we
couldn't afford more they were expensive
but by the late eighties early 90s
despite the upgrades they were becoming
a little long in the tooth a bit slow by
that time we were equivalent ectasia I
decided that we would sell them off and
my daughter bought one and even in 1993
she took mr. Cambridge with her to do
all her essays in her English degree
which she did and even when she did a
low conversion course afterwards going
right through to 1997 it still served a
very well indeed so it's become a kind
of family heirloom I put it away in a
cupboard at home and almost forgot all
about it but now what better timing than
to have a fully working Mac I don't know
if you notice that the thing when it
first booted up it came up with a smiley
face and for people who hated computers
this was wonderful it clearly loves me
I'm not scared of computers anymore
it's so friendly what you're seeing here
is a little bit of the kind of
technology that was developed at this
legendary Xerox PARC
place it's very scaled-down it had to
meet a killing price point so for
example you don't get the Xerox out a
three-button Mouse you get a one-button
mouse you get the 9 inch screen a small
keyboard floppy disc reader Steve Jobs
was not a person that liked hobbyist
computing he really wanted a smooth
thing like this preferably as
impenetrable as possible he never really
had the idea of upgrading things or
letting me rameters into his beautiful
creation so the story went out it was
going to be $600 and not just sold in
RadioShack the selling Kmart so it would
become a cool accessory for your home or
even shock horror a business computer
well they didn't make the 600 they
didn't make the $600 by a factor of
three when it first came out it was
$1,800 and looking back in the archives
now I find that that was for the
utterly minimal configuration with a
hundred and twenty eight kilobytes now
the engineers again according to the
stories I read unbeknownst the jobs
featured a backplane in there that was
capable of taking half a megabyte but
they didn't tell jobs because he didn't
made them take it out because it's going
to add to the cost and it will encourage
people getting into the back of the
Machine and daring to transfer with it
and upgrade it but of course when
upgrades became so necessary
it was probably jobs his idea all along
now remember we're back in the era of
command-line computers we're back in the
era of ms-dos we're back in the era for
those of us brought up on UNIX were
you're quite happy just typing in on a
command-line and things happen but here
is a completely new way of doing
computing you point at things you click
you drag your size and so on so this is
so familiar to you now because we're all
used to windows-based systems
Wow these things are called folders they
haven't existed before and when you look
at it you think Ida spider rewriting and
and and it's all black and white and
this changed the world oh yes it did
looking under applications listen to the
disk click Wow
Mac draw I think that's probably a
pretty good one actually just to show
you something of what was so
revolutionary about this and which you
certainly could not do on one of those
dumb terminals or character-based let's
draw ourselves a rectangle with action
so that we're now so familiar to you
I put the cursor arrow on the top left
hand corner to be and I drag out a
rectangle and there it comes with all
its points on it where you can drag it
to become wider or shallower or move the
whole thing bodily and so on select text
hello
what more could you wish for the
graphics design and graphic arts
community just loved it they've never
been able to do this thing sort of thing
before certainly not on something as
relatively affordable we won't save the
changes
zoom leave an even a little pop-up like
that saying do you want to save this oh
yes yes what's up protection would it be
for losing your work before yeah what do
you mean for doing the wrong click yeah
if you run looks an awful lot but you
know yes Sean and I thought it would be
a good idea just to show you a simple
game because yes it came with games
here's one that my daughter and I used
to play a lot it's very simple but we
loved it dearly
it's called Mombasa as you have already
seen it is in a word slow
it's a tile matching game the aim of the
game is to drill down through all of the
piles that you see here matching them as
you go along and eventually to end up
with absolutely nothing at all it was
wonderful
just being able to play games with
graphics proper graphics on the screen
the Macintosh was a success in a way in
1984 but not quite in the total way that
Steve Jobs wanted as I think I've
already explained the graphics arts
community loved it even education and
high schools liked it computer science
departments in universities liked it
the big problem was you could not afford
in those days at eighteen hundred two
thousand dollars a throw to start
equipping a 100-seat terminal room with
these things you had a few of them to
show the nature of the concept and that
was a big big problem for quite some
time now of course since it had to be
$1,800 and not the six hundred dollars
that was planned Steve Jobs with what
his colleagues always correctly called
his reality distortion field made the
following proposition hey if it's $1,800
like that's expensive so therefore it
must be a business machine it didn't
really convince the business community
and of course in many ways
the real winner from all of this a few
years later was Bill Gates because what
this did do was throw down the gauntlet
to Bill Gates to say you're good to have
to match this and exceed it because this
is the way it will go in the future so
we're left with the thing that used to
win a rage Steve Jobs it's wonderful
steam it's cute but he's a bit of a toy
what is it for there was an answer to
that and it came with the advent of a
piece of kit that Steve Jobs had helped
to bankroll the apple laserwriter was a
laser printer as we would call them
nowadays it had got this wonderful new
typesetting language inside it and if
that could be teamed up with a Macintosh
maybe this really would change
everything well did it hmm that's
another story
tell them to think again and he said to
them very memorably because he didn't
like mentioning the world he said it's
gotta be like it is on the Macintosh
that's a really good question and
personally I've almost lost count it's
it's certainly a couple dozen